Hermann Göring was second only to Hitler
in the hierarchy of the Third Reich.
Commander of the Luftwaffe, acting Prime Minister
of Prussia, President of the Reichstag, and
Hitler’s designated successor – Göring’s
Nazi resume was almost unparalleled.
Born in Bavaria in 1893, Göring was the son
of a professional soldier and governor in
West Africa.
He followed his father’s footsteps and joined
the military in 1912.
He served in the Luftwaffe during World War
I, and took over the command of “The Red
Baron” Manfred von Richthofen’s old squadron.
Although he won several awards for bravery
and his numerous victories, Göring wasn’t
popular with the other pilots, seemingly due
to his arrogance.
After joining the fledgling Nazi party in
1922, Göring quickly became indispensable
and was instrumental in the Nazi take-over
of the German government.
After Hitler became Chancellor, he appointed
Göring as Prussian Minister of the Interior,
Commissioner for Aviation, and Commander-in-Chief
of the Prussian Police and Gestapo.
Göring never hesitated to enjoy the perks
of his exalted position.
He had a magnificent palace in Berlin as well
as a luxurious hunting lodge named in honor
of his late wife Carin, who died in 1931.
He loved to play dress-up and would change
his uniforms several times a day, proudly
displaying all his medals.
It was also joked among the press at the time
that he probably bathed in his uniform.
Despite Göring’s own Godfather, Dr. Hermann
Epenstein Ritter von Mauternburg, having been
an exceptionally successful businessman of
Jewish ancestry (and a man who his mother
had a long lasting, open affair with, with
his elderly father turning a blind eye to
it and allowing his young wife to live with
Epenstein), Göring was an advocate of the
elimination of the Jews from the German economy
and infamously ordered the “architect of
the Holocaust” Reinhard Heydrich to “carry
out all preparations with regard to . . . a
general solution [Gesamtlosung] of the Jewish
question in those territories of Europe which
are under German influence …”
In 1939, Göring had serious reservations
about his Luftwaffe being ready to face the
Royal Air Force in battle, but Hitler pushed
for the acceleration of the war plans and
the war began anyway.
At this point, Göring was at the peak of
his power and popularity, and Hitler trusted
him implicitly.
But despite many early victories, the Germans
couldn’t maintain their momentum.
As Germany’s fortunes grew dimmer, Göring’s
standing with Hitler and the German people
began to falter.
At a time when most Germans were living hand-to-mouth,
Göring’s lifestyle of extreme excess was
no longer admired.
His tendency to make bold claims to Hitler
and not produce results didn’t hold him
in good stead either.
The final straw was on April 23, 1945, when
Berlin was close to falling.
Göring, who had been declared by Hitler to
be his successor if anything should happen
to him, met with other officials and decided
to take over as Hitler was trapped in Berlin.
(Hitler would commit suicide just a week later.)
When Göring officially requested Hitler approve
the decision, Hitler was furious and charged
Göring with treason.
He then ordered Göring’s arrest, and stripped
him of his rank and membership in the Nazi
party.
When Göring surrendered to the Allies in
Austria on May 8, 1945, he did it, at least
in theory, as a civilian.
GöringDetentionReportTo his apparent surprise,
Göring was put on trial for war crimes at
Nuremberg.
During his trial, according to American intelligence
officer and psychologist Captain Gustave Gilbert,
when he interviewed him, Göring was “defensive
and deflated and not very happy over the turn
the trial was taking.
He said that he had no control over the actions
or the defense of the others, and that he
had never been anti-Semitic himself, had not
believed these atrocities, and that several
Jews had offered to testify on his behalf.”
Despite being “deflated,” Göring defended
himself with great vigor and skill putting
his vaunted 138 IQ to work (tested while in
custody during the trial), occasionally outwitting
the prosecution.
After watching the films that documented the
atrocities committed in the concentration
camps, Göring claimed he was shocked at what
was depicted and felt that the films had to
have been faked somehow.
Unsurprisingly given he was second only to
Hitler in the Nazi party, nobody believed
for a second that Göring hadn’t known about
what was happening in those camps.
In the end, Göring was found guilty on all
four counts: conspiracy to wage war, crimes
against peace, war crimes and crimes against
humanity.
The judgement read,
There is nothing to be said in mitigation.
For Göring was often, indeed almost always,
the moving force, second only to his leader.
He was the leading war aggressor, both as
political and as military leader; he was the
director of the slave labour programme and
the creator of the oppressive programme against
the Jews and other races, at home and abroad.
All of these crimes he has frankly admitted.
On some specific cases there may be conflict
of testimony, but in terms of the broad outline,
his own admissions are more than sufficiently
wide to be conclusive of his guilt.
His guilt is unique in its enormity.
The record discloses no excuses for this man.
Hermann Göring was sentenced to die by hanging,
but requested to die in what he viewed as
a soldier’s death by firing squad; the court
insisted he be executed like a common criminal.
Neither side got exactly what they wanted,
but Göring still ended up just as dead when
he ingested a cyanide tablet on this day in
history, October 15, 1946, mere hours before
his date with the hangman.
albertUnlike Hermann, his little brother,
Albert, despised the Nazi party and did just
about everything in his power to oppose them,
frequently getting himself arrested, but getting
off each time due to who his older brother
was, and occasionally via direct intervention
from Hermann.
According to the book Thirty Four, by William
Burke, Albert’s first known open act to
help the Jews was a small one.
While in Vienna, he happened upon a group
of Jewish women who had a vicious mob around
them and were being forced to scrub the streets.
When he saw this, he simply walked up to one
of the women, asked for a scrub brush from
her, and knelt down and began scrubbing the
street as well.
This didn’t sit well with the officers who
were overseeing the whole thing.
But when they realized who Albert’s brother
was, they quickly ordered the scrubbing to
stop and the mob to disperse.
In a similar incident, this one which resulted
in his own arrest, he came upon a small mob
that was harassing an elderly Jewish woman,
putting a sign around her neck that stated,
“I am a Jewish sow.”
Albert pushed his way through the crowd around
her and helped the woman escape the little
mob.
In the process of doing so, he had to physically
attack two members of the Gestapo, for which
he was ultimately arrested.
As before, once they realized who they’d
arrested, he was set free.
More significantly, Albert is thought to have
helped numerous Jewish people by helping fund
an underground movement that helped Jews escape
to freedom; he also forged his brother’s
signature on several occasions to get Jews
and others released from concentration camps
and prison.
Other times, he’d simply convince Hermann
to sign an order to let certain people go,
playing on his brother’s vanity and love
for displaying his power.
In his most daring act, he drove up to a concentration
camp and simply demanded he be given Jews
for labor for the company Skoda Works, where
Albert worked at the time.
Normally, as he had no official papers for
such a request, he would have been turned
away.
But because he was the brother of Hermann
Göring, his request was granted.
After loading his truck with as many Jews
as he could, he drove them off to a remote
area and let them go with instructions on
their best route to freedom.
After that, though, the jig was up and an
order was sent from Berlin to have him shot.
He managed to escape to a safe house, however,
and the war ended very soon after.
However, upon presenting himself to Allied
soldiers, he was promptly arrested.
Unlike his older brother, Albert was acquitted
during the Nuremberg trials, though not before
spending around a year and a half in prison,
with no one believing him that he had actually
spent the war actively working against the
Nazis and helping as many people as he could
escape their clutches.
In fact, when he first told his story after
being arrested, Major Paul Kubala noted in
Albert’s file, “The results of the interrogation
of Albert Göring constitute as clever a piece
of whitewash as we have ever seen.”
However, Albert finally did find someone willing
to listen in Major Victor Parker.
He had given Parker a list of 34 Jews he knew
the names of that he had personally helped
escape.
Again, according to the book Thirty Four,
by an extraordinary coincidence, one of the
Jews on the list was Major Parker’s uncle.
After verifying the claim with his uncle,
he pursued the other names on the list who
all testified in Albert’s defense and he
was finally set free.
Unfortunately, after the war he found himself
largely shunned due to his association with
his brother and that few knew of Albert’s
real activities during the war.
As a result, he struggled to find work for
the remainder of his life and ultimately became
an alcoholic.
As his health began to fail and death was
imminent in 1966 (he was dying of pancreatic
cancer), Albert decided to marry his housekeeper.
This was not out of love, but simply because
by doing so, she would then be entitled to
his government pension, making sure she would
be taken care of financially after her services
as his housekeeper were no longer required.
He died a week later in December of 1966.
Due to Albert’s strong resemblance to his
aforementioned Godfather, Dr. Hermann Epenstein;
the fact that it was shortly after Albert’s
birth that Epenstein declared he was going
to be the Godfather to all Albert’s mother’s
children; the fact that Albert’s sister
claimed Albert was Epenstein’s favorite;
and that the affair between Epenstein and
Albert’s mother started well before Albert’s
birth, it is rumored that Albert was actually
the son of Dr. Epenstein.
However, this is generally discounted by most
historians because the dates just barely don’t
line up, given a lengthy trip Albert’s mother
took to Haiti ending in mid-1894.
For reference, Albert was born on March 9,
1895.